he hasn't fought you but he did fight
Tyson Fury yes oh why did he fight Tyson
for you instead of you because Tyson
Fury doesn't have any bells there's more
reason if they were to answer and if
Tyson was thoughts about my view I feel
like Tyson had some mental issues and he
had a free layoff and three years is a
long time to take out and I think it was
a a good name but he must have 40 was an
easy fight because he thought he was
getting him when he was a bit cold but
Tyson Fury is very talented very skilled
and showed that to the world when he
boxing they ended in a draw but if Tyson
rocks up on the April 13th oh that would
be that would be massive you would fight
him oh I'd love to even though you could
lose your four belts to him yeah he's
he's another big name though and for the
British public and a fight in Britain
you know the fight that Wilder and fury
had I fought for you you won so it would
be amazing to have two British
heavyweights and we'll be combining the
belts but you know in the eyes of a lot
of people fury as a champion as such
like whether it's off free so I'd love
to fight him even though yellow belt is
still flying one of the top three okay
and on you watch football - I'm not
football what's the thing you do
football
[Applause]
big big fun and you know it's
interesting cuz it's like when when I go
in to shoot you something the
preparation I learned a lot for me
actually I was studying you a little bit
how you prepare and the way that you so
relaxed then you just keep a flow in you
it's really inspiring thank you
what's the best and the worst thing
about training camp what I think you
like the most about training camp always
think it must be so intense and what's
the worst thing for you the best is just
the just the discipline that's the only
reason I like books and I never wanted
to kind of compete I sweat you it's the
message that you get from what you do
the message I got was a discipline as
boring as it sounds I needed it when I
was 80 and that's what I've got for a
great footballer as well well I used to
do a bit my day
[Applause]
because what you worked with with chris
hemsworth who's he's concentrating yeah
crikey when we did Thor that's why I'm
yeah yeah yeah he used to
I couldn't how I couldn't finish a
sentence with him before he put another
chicken in his book do you have to do
that and yeah nutrition is key
yeah and I'm learning there's so much
stuff about like vegan vegetarian
pescetarian and I'm learning and you
know so much information so I'm just
trying to figure out what you know my
diet is a key part but it's like fueling
the body with the right food with the
wet food oh yeah I'm learning what's the
treat
what's the treat for you and I always
say I think brownies and apple crumble
and my favorite go-to oh yeah I love
them any any good bakeries and fight
scene was it I imagine it was bombed but
it was no ton of scam notes on a scandal
with them with Kate Blanchette yeah it
was a choreographed hugely good fun it
was choreographed and you had to smash
me against the bookcase I got we are
very very excited it was about the last
table filming yeah and they and and they
gave me rather to my relief that just
before doing it they gave me kind of
back thing yeah watch fitted insight you
know about that yeah new me which fitted
inside my costume so I mean she could
she smashed me again face really read
and then we drank a whole bottle of
champagne
[Applause]
look like because you're tall you look
like someone who would be good at night
yeah and I indeed I'm not I've seen
Anthony training as well I do channel
that when I'm opening a bag focus yes
just like mental what you say focus just
Zone in no oxygen for negativity yeah
okay Chris
[Music]
you